[Music]
hey guys what's up don't you love
ironman because i do and lately there is
a new version of him in the comics and
he now has the power of a god and that
even the living tribunal oblivion and
the others would rather let him be than
intervene and try to stop him this got
me thinking is this the first time that
tony stark or iron man has had the
powers of a god in him well for some it
would seem like yes but in fact
there have been five times that iron man
has wielded powers of such an extreme
level that it could be considered
godlike there are a couple of armors
that gave him such abilities a couple
that he has by himself the init power of
a god and one that could be classified
in that category so let's get to it
number one the iron hammer also known as
stock odinson he is from earth's 616
reality the origins of this unique
iteration of the character came to be
when gamora using the soul stone
accidentally created a warped reality
where the souls of different beings are
merged together inside this warped
reality iron man and thor were merged
together into iron hammer in this form
he possesses the powers of thor which
includes a very long life span
superhuman strength and durability and
also the powers of lightning and thunder
basically an asgardian god with the
intellect of tony stark
the design of the iron hammer
armor consists of a hybrid of mid
guardian technology with that of the
other 10 realms derived from the
intuitive knowledge of asgardian
technology the runes engraved in the
suit chest plate acted as a power source
for the suit the suit mainly provides
enhanced endurance and durability adding
to the asgardian physiology
the final piece of the armor which
unlocks its full power is mjolnir iron
or neon iron a hammer made of coal iron
this hammer can be used to release
powerful electrical discharges and
concussive blasts just like the mjolnir
hammer of thor and also absorb energy as
well as summoning the bifrost like the
stormbreaker
number 2 iron god this is the latest
iteration of iron man and he now has in
his possession to power cosmic and that
makes him able to do absolutely
everything in this form he could alter
his size to planetary scale travel
across the universe as he pleases and
even warp and manipulate reality as he
wishes he could look forth into the
future events and watch the various
scenarios that would unfold if he did
anything he could also look back into
the past and try to change things in one
of the scenarios in his head he even
vaporized all the avengers fantastic 4
and the x-men in an instant
with the cosmic power imbued in him he
forms a very unique armor around him and
with that he confronts and even defeats
kovac another character imbued with the
same power cosmic the bell took place
across interstellar space and these two
absolutely gigantic sized beings even
hurt moons and planets at one another an
iron man aaron god also smashed a dead
earth on karvak's face
aaron god seals kovac in a dead universe
but was intervened by the cosmic
entities the living tribunal eternity
oblivion master order and chaos and even
death and even the in-betweener but none
of them directly tries to confront iron
god and left him to his own
number 3 the god killer iron man armor
the third on this list is the god killer
armor which is a 25 000 foot tall armor
that was used as a weapon of mass
destruction
the god killer armor was designed to
kill the celestials by billions
by the aspirants a rivalry of the cosmic
beings according to the recorder 451 the
god killer single-handedly reduced the
number of celestials from as many as the
stars in the heavens to the few
remaining today
although how it did it is unknown
god killer has never been shown to
deploy any weapons so iron man got a
hold of this armor and fought the
celestials in one instance but was
forced to destroy it when all of the
celestials attack it all at once
number 4 infamous iron man this
alternate version of iron man is the
most intriguing because the code of
armor isn't worn by tony stark this time
it's won by viktor von doom doctor doom
instead not only did the infamous iron
man have the most advanced armor and all
of its abilities but he also had all of
victor von doom's magical skills doom as
one of marvel's most powerful magicians
has the ability to alter matter and
reality he may also travel through time
and space to other realms including
mystical planes where characters such as
mephisto resign doom was one of the most
powerful iron man versions ever both
powerful and smart and with the armor he
was truly godlike
and lastly the extremity iron man this
last one is a very powerful armor
possessed by iron man that can even
overpower and take control of celestials
this armor was seen in the king and
black comics this was a fusion of the
symbiote dragon and a techno-organic
virus called the extremists as a
creation of null the symbiote dragons
possess immense powers even more
powerful than regular symbiotes
following its infusion with the
extremist virus and merging with a suit
of iron man's model 70 armor the
extremit also developed new and advanced
powers greatly augmenting the suit's
capabilities to a point where even a
celestial that was turned by null fell
to it and became a puppet of iron man
well if you could control a celestial
then you truly have godlike abilities
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and with that we come to the end
of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
[Music]
you